[موسيقى]
مافيا خرخيل اسرائيليه ليس عنوان فيلم
اثاره بل من اكثر العصابات القاتله
للحقيقه والمثيره للاضطرابات في العلمين
الافتراضي والحقيقي شعارها لا اخلاق ولا
تمييز مؤسسه الطاقم الاقرب الى مرتزقه
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي الشقيقان قال
وزهار حنان عمل زهير سابقا في احد اجهزه
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه انضم اليه ملاحقا
ميشيميدان هو ايضا الرجل استخبارات سابق
متخصص في الحب النفسيه وحملات التاثير على
الراي العام يستخدم كل من طال وزهار اسما
مستعارا هذه مقاطع من التحقيق الاستقصائي
الذي كشف عنهم وعن نشاطاتهم المزعزعه
للاستقرار على مدى عقدين من الزمن تدخل
طاقم خورخيب اكثر من 30 عمليه انتخابيه
عبر العالم تلاعبوا بنتائجها باستخدام
القرصنه والتخريب ونشر المعلومات المضلله
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
يتباهى طال بعمليات القرصنه التي قام بها
فريقه امام ثلاثه صحفيين قدموا انفسهم على
انهم زبائن يريدون خدمات خرقي في دوله
افريقيه مضطربه يخبرهم بان قائمه زبائنه
تضم وكالات استخبارات وحملات انتخابيه
وشركات خاصه من جميع انحاء افريقيا
وامريكا الجنوبيه والوسطى والولايات
المتحده واوروبا اما عن الخدمات التي
توفرها المجموعه فنجد حزمه برامج متطوره
للتاثير الاعلامي وتعرف اختصارا بايمز
تتحكم في جيش ضخم من الاف الحسابات
الشخصيه الزائفه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مثل تويتر فيسبوك وتليجرام
وانستجرام ويوتيوب
الى حسابات وهميه على مواقع امازون
بمجهزه ببطاقات ائتمان ومحافظ بيتكوين
خلال ترويجه لبضاعته يذكر خرخي الهجمات
السيبرانيه التي تقدمها مجموعته يتحدث عن
هجوم ضد لجنه الانتخابات في اندونيسيا عام
2019 قبل شهر من الاقتراع استهدف ايضا
لاستفتاء الشعبي بشان استقلال اقليم
كتالونيا عن اسبانيا في 2014
بنشر انباء كاذبه في الصحافه الاسبانيه
تتحدث عن علاقه الحزب الكتالوني الانفصالي
بتنظيم داعش في الاعتراف المسجل دون علمه
تحدث رئيس المجموعه الالكترونيه عن
مشاركته في الترويج لاخبار لا اساس لها من
الصحه من اجل التاثير في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه بفنزويلا عام 2012 بهدف منع فوز
الرئيس الراحل
اخطر ما كشفه التحقيق الذي شاركت فيه اكثر
من صحيفه اجنبيه مثل الجارديان
هو ان بعض عمليات التضليل اجريت من خلال
شركه
الاسرائيليه المسجله على موقع الكتروني
تديره وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه لتعزيز
الصادرات العسكريه